[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département à ces
parties a pour le sommaire cyclisme les
championnats de france sur route seront
organisées à mantes-la-jolie du 28 juin
au 1er juillet le parcours a été
officiellement dévoilé ce jeudi par la
fédération française tous les détails
dans cette liste sport football la
danone nations cup la plus importante
compétition de football au monde réservé
aux enfants de 10 à 12 ans était
programmée ce samedi à clairefontaine
parmi les 90 participants on pouvait
noter la présence de l'as nancy lorraine
de l'olympique lyonnais aux deux le
delehaye sera plus de renseignements à
suivre marathon tv 78 vous propose de
découvrir l'homme qui a fait le buzz
lors du dernier marathon de paris son
nom à sidy diallo
à 63 ans et tim montant a couru à pieds
nus qui a terminé en moins de quatre
heures nous avons pu le rencontrer
coup de projecteur maintenant sur cette
semaine un riche en sport
[Musique]
du 28 juin au 1er juillet se tiendront
les championnats de france de cyclisme
sur route pour cette édition 2010 8 les
yvelines ont été retenus le parcours a
été officiellement a dévoilé ce jeudi 19
avril les cyclistes s'élanceront depuis
la commune de mantes la jolie dans le
nord du département les détails avec
mélanie poké et nicolas d'henri la
collégiale notre dame en témoin de la
course
en juin prochain les polos ton feront ne
boucle autour de mantes-la-jolie un
circuit dans le vexin en soit le
parcours il n'est pas d'une difficulté
extraordinaire par contre on change
énormément de rythme et c'est ça je
trouve qu'ils donnent à ce côté
technique à ce circuit des boucles de 21
km 104 km pour les femmes 253 pour les
hommes et plusieurs traversées de la
scène un circuit qui devrait sourire aux
sprinteurs je pense qu'il manque une
réelle difficulté pour faire vraiment la
différence est que
malheureusement avec
vue qui a pas de quotas dans les équipes
et qu'on se retrouve parfois avec des
équipes comme la française des jeux où
ils sont 26 coureurs c'est très facile
de contrôler sur un circuit comme celui
là et pour réchapper un sprint il va
falloir
une course de mouvement j'aurais sans
doute aimé un peu plus dur mais bon
je pense qu'il ya il ya ce qu'il faut
quand même après c'est les coureurs qui
font la course
c'est vrai que ces dernières années il
ya eu plus dur mais il ya aussi eu moins
dur donc voilà je pense qu'on peut comme
comme comme souvent on peut avoir un
grand sprinteur qui peut passer et où
alors on préférera pour les puncheurs
les championnats de france reviennent en
ile-de-france vingt ans après montlhéry
en 97
une nouvelle compétition cycliste pour
le département c'est un très beau sport
c'est un sport praticable par tout le
monde et à tout âge
et puis c'est un sport qui est un sport
de plein air symbolique de ce
département 8 maillot bleu blanc rouge
seront attribués du 28 juin au 1er
juillet verdict dans deux mois pendant
ces championnats de france et
spectateurs pour notamment apercevoir à
locale le cycliste professionnel il
biennois kevin reza
le coureur de l'équipe vitalla concept a
pu reconnaître le tracé jeudi dernier
notre journaliste mélanie pau qui a pu
le rencontrer juste après les tours de
reconnaissance
kévin réza bonjour alors vous êtes les
en 1988 à versailles dans les yvelines
mais vous faites pour premiers coups de
pédales a plutôt est-ce que vous revenez
dans le département de temps en temps
oui si je reviens parce que c'est mais
quand même et en entraînement donc je
connais enfin la plupart des routes
puisqu'il n'a beaucoup mais oui si je
reviens à c'est assez fréquemment
mes parents habitent heures
à puteaux en effet et puis j'en profite
pour venir venir rouler avec le copain
et reconnaître et ça crie alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes chez vital concept
après la française des jeux en groupe
car pourquoi ce choix d'équipé là
c'était un choix qui a été mûrement
réfléchie assez assez tôt dans la saison
il me fallait un peu de changement une
nouvelle motivation un nouvel enjeu donc
le projet de jérôme pineau main avant de
ma vraiment plus et son état d'esprit ce
qui ce qu'il veut projetée à travers cet
été c'était cette équipe là donc ça m'a
vraiment plu et ça me
ça me correspond et je suis vraiment
content d'avoir intégré cette équipe
vous en êtes à 7 ans de
professionnalisme de très belles places
que ce soit sur le tour du pays basque
ou parfois le tour d'espagne
vous avez un grève une course qui vous
tend les bras peut-être championnat de
france oui c'est clair les chemins de
france et c'est vraiment une victoire de
prestige on a un maillot pendant un an
présente les couleurs de la france
après j'ai vraiment pas de consoeurs en
particulier parce que
ça fait ça fait huit ans que je suis
professionnel je n'ai jamais encore eu
victoire chez les pros donc j'essaie de
décrocher ma première victoire mais bon
après j'ai pas désespéré j'ai des places
d'honneur qui sont qui sont de très
belles places d'honneur
donc j'espère d'ici là décrocher ma
première histoire on né le 19 avril mais
de reconnaître le parcours du
championnat de france à mantes-la-jolie
donc sur vos terres natales qu'est ce
que vous en pensez de ce parcours c'est
un parcours très complet qui est
présente trois difficultés
il ya aussi des parties assez assez
venteuse qui qui pointent être assez
assez dangereuse aujourd'hui et des très
bonnes conditions pour faire du vélo
mais dans un bon c'est pas commencer
comment ça va être mais sympa quoi qui
m'inspire et qui peut aussi inspiré mon
équipe vital princeps akinfeev et en
espérant ramener le maillot à la maison
vous allez jouer un rôle dedans où vous
allez travailler pour vous vos leaders
peut-être bryan coquard oui après voilà
c'est un parcours que bras ne peut peut
espérer briller
voilà
une quoi elles sont aussi après les cci
croire qu'ils font qui font la course
qui ja c'est aussi la course
on sait jamais comment une course se
décide à l'avance donc faudra être
opportuniste pour jouer sa propre carte
si c'est pas le cas eh ben on fera tout
pour brian une particularité cette année
à cause de la coupe du monde les
horaires sont modifiés départ à 8h45
est-ce que ça va être dur ça va être une
autre préparation oui j'ai appris cette
affaire c'est tony gallopin qui me l'a
appris
ouais c'est ces petites nouveautés qui
est qui va changer pas mal de choses
faudra se lever de bonne heure se
préparer différemment mais bon après on
est on est coureur professionnel on a
connu des horaires un peu difficile de
ce type là donc on va s'y préparer et
pourquoi pas dès maintenant
merci kévin réza on vous suivra donc le
1er juillet pour ce qui est de la course
en ligne
on jouait ce week-end sur les terrains
de handball a rien ne va plus chez les
féminines de montigny le bretonneux dans
le championnat de nationale 2 les
inhumant ten se sont inclinés dans le
derby vinoy contre conflans l'extérieur
sur le score de 30 à 27
malgré les neuf buts di menna benno mari
cette treizième défaite de la saison
pourrait condamner montigny le
bretonneux à une descente en nationale 3
les filles de dénicher les compte quatre
points de retard sur le premier non
relégable toujours handball mais cette
fois ci chez les garçons plaisir s'est
largement imposé sur son terrain contre
saint mandé à l'occasion de la 17e
journée du championnat de nationale 3 le
score est sans appel 33 à 25 avec six
buts inscrits par alexandre roger au
classement le promu plaisir wap et
envisager une montée en fin de saison
avec 11 victoires engrangées les
yvelinoises sont deuxièmes du
championnat la place de barragiste pour
l'accession à la division supérieure
on ouvre une page baseball dans ce
magazine un tournoi européen amical pour
les moins de 15 ans était organisée ce
week-end au stade jean marc et celle de
montigny le bretonneux six équipes dont
deux des pays-bas venu d'homs
d'amsterdam et de rotterdam se sont
affrontés sur deux jours de compétition
on écoute les réactions des joueurs au
micro de nicolas d'henry je trouve que
c'est super parce qu'on peut se mesurer
à des équipes sont plus fortes comme un
roi où les équipes néerlandaises
et du coup j'ai pu jouer à plusieurs
postes et ça nous fait gagner de
l'expérience et je trouve c'était super
g bien plus élevé à des équipes
étrangères notamment dix pays bas qui
qui ont un très bon niveau et les matchs
sont beaucoup plus intense est beaucoup
plus dur à jouer
grâce à eux je pense que c'est un très
bon tournoi et c'est super de jouer dans
ce tout nouveau stade
j'ai entendu dire avec il avait été
ouvert récemment en plus je pense que
c'est un bon tournoi car on peut se
tester face à d'autres équipes à
d'autres pays et c'est une bonne
expérience
toujours en baseball les seniors des
cougars de monti le bretonneux jouer ce
week-end contre les ducks de
saint-just-saint-rambert pour le compte
de la 3e journée du championnat de d1
les cougars l'ont emporté 14 à 2 dans le
premier match puis se sont inclinés 6 à
3 dans le second
des résultats qui permettent aux iie
montanes être en milieu de classement
avec deux matches de retard
prochain rendez vous le 6 mai contre
haut rang à domicile
nous allons maintenant parler soccer
dans ce magazine dans le championnat de
d1 de district billancourt s'est imposé
1 à 0 sur le terrain de gargenville en
match en retard une victoire importante
pour les guyancourt toit grâce à ce
résultat
ils reviennent à un petit point de la
troisième place détenue par détenu par
leurs adversaires du jour
notre montagne se dressera sur le chemin
de guyancourt le 6 mai prochain le
leader du championnat a les mureaux on
continue à part du football dans le
championnat de r4 régionale 4 trappe
recevez les gobelins en match en retard
une rencontre qui s'est soldée par un
match nul 1 but partout vous une
rencontre qui n'arrange pas les
trappistes dans la course au maintien à
montage signé sandrine fontaine
une égalisation dans les ultimes
secondes de la partie les rouges de
trappes y ont cru jusqu'au bout ce
dimanche 22 avril contre l'équipe des
gobelins en match en retard du
championnat de régionale 4 pourtant tout
avait mal débuté pour les trappistes
dominé en début de partie ils concèdent
l'ouverture du score mettra pas fait
preuve de caractère en égalisant face au
leader du championnat
score final un but partout on se dit
quand on a toutes façons plus rien à
perdre
la preuve sur un des derniers coups de
pied arrêtés notre gardien est monté on
se contentait pas de doute la défaite on
on voulait absolument arracher le point
du match nul et voire même la victoire
mais pas à s'étendre
malheureusement on était maintenue
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu de ya pas
une banque les joueurs ont tout donné
en plus de la chaleur c'est un peu coupé
que c'est pour nous larmes de mon côté
je vends pas de réparer ce qu'ils ont
fait ce qu'il fallait avant tout donner
un but à la 90e minute si pour avoir une
importance cruciale pour la suite du
championnat trap est actuellement 12e
sur 14 équipes engagées qui n'aura
semaine en cinq matches on a encore
trois domiciles faut qu'on prenne des
points le plus rapidement possible pour
assurer le maintien qui était pas
l'objectif de début de saison mais vu
les événements a dû faire avec
et voilà le sien c'est un bon match et
nous prônons mais en fait on quand on
fait un match en retard
donc ça permet de gagner encore en vrac
et quoi en fait un trois points donc là
nous ferons quand deux victoires pour
assurer le maintien pour la première de
ses cinq finales à disputer d'ici la fin
de la saison les trappistes se
dépasseront ce dimanche 29 avril sur le
terrain de val de france une équipe
classée dernière de ce championnat
la danone nations cup la plus importante
compétition de football au monde réservé
aux enfants de 10 à 12 ans était
organisée ce samedi 21 avril à
clairefontaine
parmi les 80 équipes participantes on
pouvait noter la présence de l'as nancy
lorraine de l'olympique lyonnais ou de
l'étoile sportive de trappes des images
de nicolas landry un montage de à xavier
jaillard je l'appelle une d'âgés 11e
jour
gemma paltrow cinq matches et j'ai douze
un demi et je joue à l'olympique isoler
les footballeurs sont venus des quatre
coins de la france pour participer à la
danone nations cup l'un des plus gros
tournois pour les enfants âgés de 10 à
12 ans pour cette édition 2010 8 la
compétition était organisée ce samedi 21
avril sur les terres de l'équipe de
france à clairefontaine
le fait de venir à clairefontaine une
année coupe du monde pour ses enfants
filles et garçons
bah je pense que c'est une forme
d'aboutissement en tout cas on essaye de
leur proposer à une part du rêve que
veut provost proposé l'événement à moyen
terme eu parmi les quatre ans formations
engagées lui et sera pas envoyé une
équipe masculine et féminine
ça fait toujours plaisir parce que c'est
ça l'endroit où des pros ils ont joué
enfin qui joue et il ya beaucoup
d'adversité
on essaye de donner le maximum de nous
pour pour essayer d'aller le plus loin
possible
les performances réalisées devant les
yeux de leurs parents elle en a pas
dormi de la nuit
il s'est réveillé vraiment heureux c'est
sa journée et ben c'est le rêve d'un
enfant aujourd'hui qu'il exauce beaucoup
d'émotion on voit beaucoup de choses les
enfants enfin c'est très plaisant de
voir autant d'enfants jouer avec des
grandes équipes c'est vraiment très très
intéressant de participer à cet
événement le estrade terminera
finalement la 28e place du tournoi avec
une victoire de prestige 4 à 0 contre le
paris saint germain et qui pourra se
consoler également avec le titre de
champion du fair play
les deux finalistes joueront quant à eux
le 20 mai à montpellier
[Musique]
je vous propose à présent de découvrir
un sportif qui défient à la chronique et
qui a fait le buzz lors du dernier à
marathon de paris son nom à sidy diallo
a 63 ans est il monte un coup de pied nu
et a terminé en moins de quatre heures
mais cet athlète est un habitué la cour
au total 21 marathon pieds nus sur ses
160 participation au marathon en huit
ans rencontre avec un homme qui brise
les codes
il a fait le buzz au dernier marathon de
paris à mes côtés sidy diallo 63 ans qui
nous vient tout droit de montigny le
bretonneux
sa particularité ils courent pieds nus
mais ce n'est pas une première pour sidy
diallo qui a déjà réalisé à de
nombreuses reprises cette performance 6
10 vous confirmez
oui paris c'était mon 21e marathon pieds
nus mais c'est vrai que c'est le
marathon qui a été le plus facile pour
moi parce que quand je ne suis remis à
courir pieds nus
ça demande beaucoup de temps pour
s'adapter et paris les conditionnent
paris cité parfait mes pieds
on fait pas mal de progrès à gilles épié
c'est les pieds les jambes 1 c'est pas
seulement la plante des pieds puisque
tout le monde pense à la plante des
pieds mais c'est le regarde tout entier
y compris les jambes qui doivent se
réadapter à la course et la marche pieds
nus quand on a utilisé des chaussures
pendant plusieurs années ou bien depuis
ça depuis sa naissance
vous courez toujours pieds nus non je
vais commencer à la première fois que je
suis sorti de chez moi à pied nu c'était
en juin 2015
de montigny et donc ça fait moins de
trois ans le début était très difficile
mais maintenant au moins sur l'asphalté
quand je suis l'asphalt généraux comme
problème pour les pieds nus et des
halles à paris je vais réaliser mon l'un
devait mal tourner les plus rapides en
3h54 et vient chez n'est donc
sept jours plus tard à bonn c'est
dimanche dernier avec un autre marathon
pieds nus et là j'ai réalisé mon
meilleur temps pieds nus sur la distance
du marathon en 3 heures 47 minutes
donc on peut dire maintenant que mes
pieds sont quasiment prêts mais ce n'est
pas encore prêt j ya des progrès mais
j'ai encore des progrès à faire pour
revenir à la façon normale découvrir et
et sans aucun problème ce n'est pas trop
dangereux de courir pieds nus
c'est un jeu redécouvrir avec les
chaussures je crois plus avec les
chaussures que pieds nus bah oui bah
écoutez moi j'ai terminé le marathon de
paris
j'étais prêt avait fait la distance en
sens inverse bon ça c'est facile de le
dire les gens volaient pas si facile de
le dire ok il a dit qu'il pouvait pas
mais je n'avais rien aucun problème mais
de toute façon donc sept jours plus tard
à bonn j'aurais fait la même distance
pieds nus et j'ai couru plus vite
puisque je fais 3h47 alors qu'à paris
c'était 3h54 et quel est le regard des
autres coureurs quand ils passent à côté
de vous sur un marathon il ya quelques
uns des gens qui sont unifiés je vais à
paris il y en a quelques-uns qui ont
essayé qu'ils sont afin qu'ils ont pris
le processus est peut-être qu'ils
peuvent pas que fait le marathon mais en
a qui ont en fait c'est une tendance a
compris que c'est mon t-shirt intendance
et quand on s'y met on a envie de
continuer mais bon il ya des jeunes qui
ont des problèmes parce que peut-être
qu'il veut aller trop vite si on à
porter les chaussures
durant toute sa vie et qu'on décide de
s'en passer
il faut réapprendre à marcher à courir
pieds nus comme les enfants avec
beaucoup de patience donc c'est le
conseil que je donne aux tous et qui se
sont lancés qui ont dénoncé parce que
ils ont vu que ce n'est pas aussi facile
alors on le voit sur votre t-shirt
courir pieds nus rejoint la tendance ou
le disiez précédemment vous voulez créer
un mouvement non il existe déjà
moi je le joue et je veux que les autres
en face à face à la même chose vous
savez disons que c'est une mode
qu'ils viennent d'amérique du nord des
états unis
l'awb a coulé en marchant pieds nus
c'est pas c'est pas quelque chose de
spécial il ya beaucoup de gens qui
courent pieds nus aux états unis et
d'ailleurs le marathon aussi avait
commencé aux états unis donc en fait
c'est une tendance américaine est en
fait une tendance américaine qui compte
qu'il revient en fait à revenir à la
case départ de l'humanité quoi quand on
courait pieds nus pour attraper les
animaux pour manger ou penser que cette
tendance peut se développer encore plus
en europe pas je l'espère oui oui
puisque j'ai pas bon il ya les
actionnaires les médias mais aussi des
gens qui m'ont écrit qui vont ont fait
part de leur expérience c'est la façon
normand à l'écouté demandez à n'importe
quelle personne qui se promène sur une
plage de sable fin qui est lui comment
il se sent vous verrez tout de suite le
bonheur sur son visage le simple fait de
se rappeler des s'imaginer marchés
pionniers nous sommes nés marcher et
courir pieds nus d'elle complètement nue
les médecins ont dit que votre technique
n'était pas forcément approprié pour la
course
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ils ont dit
ça quoi sur internet sur l'antenne de
partout pour écouter je suis mais c'est
moi même déjà non courir pieds nus en
est
goûtez y a pas de débat pas de polémique
et à rien pendant 3 millions d'années
les espèces la lignée humaine cours et
marcher pieds nus c'était très efficace
le corps humain parfait j'espère que les
auditeurs le corps humain est parfait le
corps de chaque des individus de chaque
espèce animale est parfait pour la
survie de l'espèce à son habitat naturel
il ya aucun autre animal qui portent des
chaussures et l'animal homo sapiens nous
parle de chaussures que depuis très peu
de temps sur une histoire de trois
millions d'années
donc on va on va pas faire des études
si on doit faire des études s'est montré
en quoi les je suis 100 utile et c'est
pas le cas dernière question est ce que
vous pouvez courir quand même maintenant
avec des chaussures déjà eu corée puis
amiens en fait c'est les gens pensent
toujours la réponse des pieds non c'est
l'organe toute entière
c'est l'organe tout entier qui se
développe j'ai pas du mal à courir avec
des chaussures et d'ailleurs mes pieds
mes jambes sont en meilleur état
si je vais cool avec des chaussures
peut-être que j'ai vraiment joué moins
tendance à nous blesser à propos des
gens qui disent il faut de chaussures
écoutez moi j'ai fini le marathon de
paris comme certains de vos confrères on
dit j'ai fini le marathon prêt à
recommencer
les gens qui portent des chaussures les
plus chères du monde les individus
d'homo sapiens les mieux et chaussées
peut-être qu'ils sont encore aujourd'hui
incapable de courir alors que j'ai déjà
fait marathon et que je veux dimanche
dernier que je fais une autre dimanche
prochain merci beaucoup un sidi diallo
sidy diallo recours à un nouveau
marathon pieds nus ce dimanche à anvers
à l'enregistrement réalisé la semaine
dernière avant son départ sidy diallo a
bien terminé le marathon d'anvers comme
on va le voir sur ces images
pieds nus avec un temps de 3 heures 54
minutes et 45 secondes
on ouvre une page golf comme tous les
lundis tv 60,18 vous propose de
découvrir les moments qui ont marqué
l'histoire de la plus grande compétition
de golf au monde je veux bien sûr parler
de la ryder cup
aujourd'hui le directeur du golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
paul hermitage vous présente l'un de ses
meilleurs souvenirs de la compétition à
quelques mois de l'organisation de la
ryder cup 2018 en france
regardez
[Musique]
je me souviens de 2016
on va serrer d'ouverture très émouvant
extrêmement émouvant en santé dans l'air
une envie
désespéré deux états unis d
américains pour gagner la ryder cup et
remettre un peu de piment dans les
années 20 ce qui
ma frappé le plus mon plus beau souvenir
c'était la beauté de la mise en scène de
l'événement tous ceux rouges qui étaient
partout était impressionnant même si on
soutient le bleu le peuple qu'il y avait
à la cérémonie d'ouverture à merci
derrière cette scène le fly over des
avions de combat américains solides
nationale qui est déjà magnifique mais
qui qu'il a été encore plus beau parce
que vous aviez car une personne qui le
chante et en harmonie dans tous les
réseaux tine c'est un nouveau benchmark
au niveau de la puissance de l'événement
[Musique]
les duels à l'épée les escarmouches vous
ont toujours fasciné le reportage qu'ils
y va suivre devrait vous intéresser
l'association escalibur yvelines
installé sur la commune de poissy nous a
présenté les techniques de combat d'un
chevalier du xiiie siècle nous avons
enfilé notre armure et nous avons
mouillé notre cote de maille pour vous
présenter cette discipline insolite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous propose aujourd'hui de remonter
le temps et de vous arrêter à l'époque
du moyen-age une association baptisée
escalibur yves hinse et créé il ya cinq
ans ab côté son président arnaud de
maizière arnaud concrètement qu'est ce
qu'on va faire aujourd'hui avance équipe
et on va se mettre nu et on va combattre
comme au xiiie siècle
c'est pas trop lourd tout et d'armures
non les gens y arriver on y va on va y
arriver
oui c'est parti à l'ope
alors à redon on est devant la fameuse
armure allait proposer de quelle matière
expliqué nous voilà en fait vous avez
l'armure d'un homme d'armes xiiie siècle
dont quelqu'un de comme assez aisée
c'est pas forcément un chevalier ça
plutôt être un piéton donc on va voir
une première couche de textile faire
bien absorber les coûts
c'est par dessus en mettre une couche de
métal de métal alors là on à de la
maille alors je le regardais déjà je
vais un peu soupeser ah oui
effectivement
oui c'est 15 kg 12 et 15 kg ha oui mais
le poids total c'est autour de 25 kg
c'est bon je suis entré dépôts et à
certains endroits on va avoir des
parties métalliques solide mais c'est
surtout une armure textile parce que
l'essentiel de la défense
qu'est ce sera compliqué
donc bouclier cote de maille tout
l'équipement 25 kg c'est ça à peu près
bon ballon filer ses parties que des
pâquis pour rien non vous pouvez tester
pour attester
ok tu as des armes doivent oublier ton
épée sors ton ep
fastidieux vient de sortir c'est bon tu
as toutes les chances
ok pas beaucoup d'armure il faut
protéger que le bouclier donc tu vas
essayer de toujours le temps de repos
près comme ça ton ep t'as pas de
protection aux mains il faut que tu as
frappé qui met en garde
je pense que tu feras petit tournoi b c
à puis vient le dos droit
voilà là tu attaques pas tu reviens tu
es tu essayes de parec le bouclier les
bruits tous et bonne chance
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur
donc
si j'ai bien compris comme ça
ah oui d'accord pour pouvoir y aller
gentiment
[Musique]
résiste résister à pluie
les gens disent les gens
en moins cher
[Musique]
très très très bien ça va suffire je
pense que tu es prêt à rejoindre
l'association
je suis prêt tu es prêt je me retire et
la côte de mal parce que j'ai vraiment
trop trop chaud tous les ans pas la
cotisation
effectivement
[Musique]
merci beaucoup pour ce cours
d'initiation alors comment fait pour
s'inscrire à l'association à tous les
détails sont sur le site
excalibur et bwin.fr ne vous fait pas
que la reconstitution on fait aussi des
animations dont des protections adaptées
et encore plus dangereux encore plus
dangereux c'est moins lourd peut-être au
niveau d'armure plus chaud du show bon
ben on va continuer à tester un petit
peu ce sport plaisir
[Musique]
heureusement que le ridicule ne tue pas
on referme ce magazine par un
rendez-vous les templiers d'elancourt se
déplace ce samedi à 19 heures sur le
terrain des spartiates d'amiens pour le
choc de cette 9e journée du championnat
de 2e division
les deux équipes occupent actuellement
les deux premières places du classement
et sont toutes les deux encore en
ballottage pour l'accession en première
division
le combat s'annonce rude sur le stade du
grand marais c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi très
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]